I just point out a lot us did this well
however for all of us there's a bit of a
lesson here right which is before you
apply calculus feedbag to all of that
algebra all those logs or the trig
identities that you know before you
devote yourself to calculus because you
can see here right I mean Adam in above
we're going to have to use product rule
here because there's a you add a V but
secondly as its presented to us there's
chain rule happening here but we don't
need to go to chain rule right so how
can we use my lovers before I start
differentiating to actually simplify
this thing I can take that to out the
front right this is the derivative oh
there's my x + 1 + 1
just picking back up the suggestion is
i'm going to write that as 2 and because
I've lazy I'll keep it no you're a rat
log messy I'm going to go natural laws
and just write it like that okay so you
can see so no no so this is the whole
point is the whole point of what I've
done because this is materially easy to
differentiate than this in fact that
that too i can just bring it up the
fight and not worry about it now I'm
just choosing this question as the
easiest way to pull it out this happens
whether you are differentiating it
happens when you're integrating when you
have a volume all those kinds of things
manipulating your logs that's something
we need to go back over okay it's
something we definitely so can we just
finish this out now i'll leave that to
at the front and let's differentiate
this thing i'll call that you and i'll
call that log X let's just call that be
okay good morning so what kinds of um
what way you're going to start your
differentiation okay me you dash plus
you are you happy with that yes so you
can you can continue that as you like I
think everyone was fine after this point
but it was getting to that one but you
know if you if you tried to work with
this you should have ended up with I
mean this is 2x on x squared but
sometimes we forgot because like it's
also a fairly can i point out it's an
early question it's an early question
your brains not warmed up yet this
happens by the way I'm just going to
make a note over all about the UM
Fortuna exam the structure of the HSE
tunity right three hours long three
hours long who knows off the top of
their head what the structure is no then
I looked enough apart papers okay so
there are some multiple-choice questions
how many on it there are 10 and then
there's fresh 11 12 13 etc okay I have
news for you right those first ten
questions even though they're the first
ten questions they are not the easiest
ten questions right quite
jun 11 that's always the easiest
question right because in there you'll
find evaluate this round this off to
tree significant figures by the way
you've got to say some stuff a
significant p 1 second was
straightforward one and two markers
right like the very very straight
forward to Marcus worked like is this
really worth too much okay all those
questions all those questions appear
here right and these questions are
deceptively difficult so my advice
wherever you begin you must return to
these questions you had time you had
time it is good I know with some of you
felt a bit stretch of the time but you
didn't have time so you've got to come
back I mean I don't like to start here
maybe if you like and then do this
afterwards but those are just things to
get your brain going ok just what is the
last question in the exam necessarily
artist Norah the last question is not
necessarily post however
okay Shh you 12 by the way if you feel
like okay this is fun I can move on then
you have other work that you can get on
with this crap particular question does
not continue the problem is saying or
which one is the hardest is that if
you're like a normal student then you're
you know strong and weak points will not
exactly line up with like it'll be this
topic or that topic and so they'll put
something at the end which maybe you may
actually be very very good at like it's
like oh this type of question I've just
nailed it I'm really good at and it's
all the way through all the courses for
example induction induction a lot of
people find very difficult but I just I
don't know what it is I i really like
induction questions like even when
they're quite long as i can find my way
through it unlike say a circle geometry
question which in extension one and
especially an extension to I'll just
beat my headache it's endlessly and I'm
like I don't see it I don't see it so
therefore if the induction Christian is
the last one which would not be
surprising in the attention one in there
you know someone like me be like what
are you so therefore you gonna watch for
things like this just read it haha okay
um for that reason wherever you begin
whether it's here or here or here the
making come back to that place I'm back
most people don't have so much trouble
like again for you guys I've said this
before and I'll say it again van six is
won or lost in that question that's it's
as simple as that right because that's
where you hemorrhaged all these very
small numbers of marks if you think
about if you think about how much work
you've gotta put in to earn like a three
mark question and like how likely you
are to get like one or two or three of
those marks right you guys are very very
likely to get two or three Zhaan those
like these question thirteenth and
fourteenth but here are like just a tiny
little thing who a mark is gone right
and you can do that two or three times
it's like wow you know 15 minutes later
that I spent less spin later in the
paper but I want to spend to do those
three other marks I've spent a huge
time but I've lost them in seconds in
this question okay just like we do you